[Music]
that we are going to inshallah use our
platforms as much as we can
to show what's going on the grand
brothers sisters it's got to them so bad
alhamdulillah with the permission of
supplemental and all praises belong to
him
our videos and most of the videos are
brothers and sisters we're looking at
hundreds and thousands to millions of
views in a matter of days
and this is really really really hurting
the israeli big time uh uh state yeah
this this apartheid state that's what
they are
okay yeah yes state that's what it is so
much so guys
they are now placing ads on our very
videos
mine yours i came across this video
brother says let's watch for ourselves
this video is not going to be long
you guys need to send this video to all
muslim youtubers
because someone notif i saw the video
but someone look at the
i saw the video
i saw the video and i thought oh my gosh
they're placing ads
and i've in my head before i can think
well like this from allah
a brother message me yeah a prophet i
know
and he messages me and he goes um i've
seen this video he
he messaged me something else he said
there's a female ad on your thing i said
okay we'd block the ads but you know
they used women for chocolate and other
kinds i said it's not my control
he said you can do specific blocking i
was like how and he sent me i was like
wow i didn't even know that yeah
so now we know that and then he goes by
the way israel was playing as and i was
like yeah
and i was like oh my gosh yeah i said
kimbrough he was here i was like
bro can you imagine allah facilitate
that because i don't know how to do aki
i know you can block certain things but
you know you can specifically block and
he sent me that i've got the messages
here look at this propaganda guys it's
unbelievable yeah
watch this this one we'll also give you
a way to block it it's very simple it'll
take you like half a minute it will take
you literally 30 seconds send this to
all the youtubers all the public figures
who are muslim because they're placing
these ads on our videos because they
know we're targeting
and exposing them watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
did you guys hear that a hummus rocket
by the way look
attacking innocent civilians we've made
it very clear yeah both sides whatever
it may be
it's disgusting okay the the thing here
is though the palestinian kids are being
blown into pieces
while the israeli illegal settlers their
children have bunkers do you get them
trying to see
let's be real okay and their rockets are
all been intercepted
yeah look at this noise here do you
think this is from my how much we've
all been incepted by well mostly most of
them have been intercepted yeah okay
watch this
listen bro they are even using
sound this explosion is most likely from
an israeli airstrike on the palestinians
killing babies
blowing them into pieces blowing them
into pieces i'm going to repeat that
over and over again
they are even using the sound effects
of their own bombings in their videos
that's how that's how desperate it's got
desperate thanksgiving
you know even that girl you noticed it
was an echo and even when you've got
different
frames yeah you can see that they're
they're different footages yes but
you've got the same sound that continues
so you know editing editing is done and
we did this when we spoke to caden
robertson he told us how editing was
down when tony wasn't punched that black
guy
exactly yeah so we can see it's
happening again
israel will protect the citizens against
hamas terror okay
can okay that's right the americans have
come as well said you need the
uh uh israel has the right to defend
itself do the palestinians have a right
to defend this well it's very important
do they have a right to defend yourself
as well we're asking a simple question
nobody is talking about this it's
unbelievable
and guys all this editing and the way
they made it seem it to be and i'm not
seeing
the people that israel international law
does say that
if you are occupied you have a right to
defend yourself yeah armed resistance
yes you're allowed but that's not being
mentioned
and and and let's be real they're
democratically elected yeah
hamas is democratically elected it's as
simple as that yeah okay hamas is
democratically elected but even obama
when he was questioned about isis he
said isis
is a a result of
on it's an unintended consequence
of our invasion in iraq exactly did
hamas exist
before this all happened no you guys
caused them
you guys are if you have a problem this
is an unintended consequence of the
occupation let's be real
you guys have caused them and this is
what's happening innocent people are
dying
so the point is this brother and sisters
it is very clear the palestinians
they don't need the special effects all
they have to do is take their camera out
and just record what's happening they
don't need special effects footages from
a different place that's gonna have to
do with the whole uh
what you're what you're trying to
portray and put this together and use
sound effects from
your actual bombings that you're doing
in in gaza and
palestinians don't even have the budget
to be buying ads
of you there are muslim youtubers
there's public figures who are raising
awareness to this because they don't
yet they don't we don't get funded by
nobody nobody funds us
all we do is raise awareness inshallah
is there anything else you'd like to add
to let's let's show people uh walk them
through how to exactly guys so it's very
simple let me just show you guys
inshallah
so there we go on the screen guys so for
any any any youtuber
will know this inshallah guys any of you
guys youtubers you know this go to your
adsense and when you go to adsense
yes you pl press block block controls go
to advertise
urls and just enter what we have on the
screen
once you've done that it's literally
this easy i did not even know this yeah
yeah there's there's there's there's a
first option on the left here first
option on the left yeah
and once you search it you will see
blocked
there we go it's blocked it on my when
it wasn't it was allowed you press block
it's as simple as that it will take you
30 seconds
so share this inshallah brother adam
sally slim
fuzzy troop and the other youtubers not
the sellouts like nasty he's a sellout
i've got video coming from
this sellout he's a palestinian it's a
sellout yeah
anyways um so brother sisters what we're
saying is inshallah um we've done the
videos inshallah and
the damage is done that's correct the
damage is done and the damage is being
done towards israel there's so much so
they are
buying youtube ads uh to show their
desperation
it's pure desperation when you have to
buy
advertising space on muslim channels
yeah and get edited footage uh use sound
effects
of actual airstrikes and make it seem
like it's harness rockets it's clear
rather than since that's the video share
it with all the youtubers they all have
to block those ads
this is your duty it is your duty to do
it it's our duty to bring you the videos
and helping china raise awareness
is your duty brothers and sisters to do
inshallah we are going to join forces
inshallah
and show people the reality of how the
massacring ethnic cleansing of the
palestinian people till next time our
video will be next video we'll be
reacting to
is the reaction video of an absolute
propaganda video of israel asking
the question what if this happened in
london well about to find out your
answer